the witcher has been one of netflix's
most popular series in recent years
having previously found a fan base as a
book series and video game franchise the
live action series is adapted from the
novels penned by polish author andrei
sabkovsky the show's first season
focuses on the exploits of three
characters across different points in
time there's geralt of rivia a monster
hunter boosted by magic siri a princess
with magic powers of her own and
yennefer a powerful sorceress as the
season progresses each character
discovers how their fates are entwined
with one another the casting of henry
cavill in the lead role of geralt made
fans of the book series curious as the
actor previously played the role of
clark kent in man of steel batman v
superman dawn of justice and justice
league and also appeared in spy films
such as the man from uncle and mission
impossible fallout of course the source
material for those franchises is
decidedly different from that of the
witcher however it didn't take long for
audiences to realize that cavill was the
perfect choice for the role fans of the
books and video games quickly warmed up
to the performer and he has been an
integral part of the series since the
very first episode in a recent interview
with the hollywood reporter cavill
explained that he is only willing to
continue the role if a very specific
condition of his is met in an in-depth
profile interview with the hollywood
reporter henry cavill reiterated his
commitment to the series proving that
his interest had not waned with two
seasons already in the books and a third
on the way he also affirmed he would be
happy to have the show go on for a whole
seven seasons in keeping with current
showrunner lauren historic's plan cavill
did add however that there was only one
caveat with his participation in the
witcher franchise he explained to the
hollywood reporter that he will remain
involved with the show quote as long as
we can keep telling great stories which
honor sepkovsky's work by all accounts
the cast and crew are also happy to keep
working with cavill in the same
interview historic spoke about how the
actor will talk to every crew member on
set to start the day asking them how
their day is going according to her it's
to the point where sometimes our 80s are
like okay we have a huge crew you can't
ask everyone his rick also spoke to
cavill's work ethic praising the man of
steel actor for his commitment and
routine preparedness she said he knows
he is number one on the call sheet and
there's a great responsibility that
comes with that a lot of times that
person can make the show a hurricane
that revolves around them henry works
hard to make that not so he's on time he
always knows his lines he always knows
his choreography and certainly always
knows his action it certainly sounds
like cavill is dedicated to the role
which is why it's no surprise that
cavill's love for the witcher predates
his role on the netflix series cavil an
avid gamer has spoken previously about
how the witcher video games from cd
projekt red were his first introduction
to the series as a whole and how hard he
campaigned to be cast in the role of
geralt of rivia cavill told the
hollywood reporter that he pursued the
role relentlessly eventually he was
asked to audition for the role while
auditions are a routine part of many
actors lives it's also something that
isn't regularly required for an actor of
his caliber and experience despite
cavill's agent assuring him that he
didn't have to do it he insisted on
complying with the request according to
the hollywood reporter when cavill's
agent expressed further skepticism at
whether he would actually go through
with it he had only one response of
course it's the witcher caval's
enthusiasm for the job has only grown
since his successful audition after the
first season of the television series
proved to be an enormous success cavill
began pushing for more dialogue in the
second season aiming to better capture
the inner monologue of the character on
full display in the book series check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one